Stefan Tietze hat was erlebt und erzählt das Florentin und auch der hat was zu sagen und das ist auch schon der Sinn von Podcastufo, Podcastufo und wir sitzen alle da und hell hinzu. Hey! Korrekt? Ja, schön, dass ihr wieder da seid. Wir sitzen ja immer hier. Ihr seid nur die, die weggehen und wiederkommen. Parasoziale Verbindung nennt man das. Ja, wir sitzen hier rum und ihr kommt manchmal in unserem kleinen Podcaststudio zu Gast. Wir kennen euch nicht. Parasoziale Verbindung. Damit herzlich willkommen zum Podcast Sufo.. Wir sind nicht eure Freunde, herzlich willkommen bei Podcast-Ufo.
Entschuldigung?
Oh, das war jetzt irgendwie.
Hast du Rock gesagt?
Herzlich willkommen zu einer Ausgabe des Das Podcast-Ufo-Podcast-Projektes 2023 TM mit mir, Stefan Thieser und dir, Florentin Will.
Korrekt, und natürlich heute unser Bandleader, Lennart.
Nice. Kannst du Beatboxen, hast du das jemals gemacht? Tatsächlich mache ich das ganz oft unter Wasser. Das ist eine neue... Norbertin ist ja die einzige Landratte, die häufiger unter Wasser ist als an Land. Genau, ja, und ich dachte mir so, es ist das alte Kindesbuch der Rekordeprinzip. Wenn du etwas nicht kannst, dann ändere es leicht ab, um eine eigene Disziplin nur für dich zu haben, in der du dann der Beste bist. Und deswegen mache ich Unterwasser-Beatboxen, weil unter Wasser klingt ja alles so, wenn du so in der Badewanne, in der Badewanne, unter Wasser klingt cool, aber es ist in der Badewanne. Und deswegen, wenn du unter Wasser bist, dann ... Besser als deine Phase, wo du es im Waschbecken gemacht hast, wo du immer wie so ein Emu den Kopf ins Waschbecken gesteckt hast. Das stimmt, aber ... Denn Emus stecken Köpfe in ihre Waschbecken. Genau. Es ist auch auf bessere Höhe wie so ein Hund, der einfach so richtig Durst hat. Was ich ja immer, wo ich mich immer schlecht fühle, weil der Mensch, wenn er richtig Durst hat, dann kann er richtig kübeln, wie du es jetzt in exakt dem Moment machst, wo du richtig schön deine Plastikflasche an die wohlgeformten Lippen setzt und du kannst richtig gut ... Glas, Glasflasche. Warum versuchst du immer dein Image zu verbessern in so unwichtigen Dingen? Sind Glasflaschen überhaupt besser? Ich weiß es nicht. Die lösen noch Waldbrände aus. Das ist ein Mehrweg von Flaschen. Ja, die lösen noch Waldbrände aus oder sowas. Ich glaube, man sollte aus Glasgläsern Wasser vom Hahn trinken. Ich finde, man sollte aus Glas nur Gläser machen und keine Flaschen. Glas, Glas, Plastikflasche, okay? Lass uns die Welt geordnet halten, nicht diese Vermischung. Sondern Beatbox sich unter Wasser und... Das ist meine Trennung. Beatboxen nur an Land, nicht unter Wasser. Ich glaube, es ist ... Ja gut, du machst diesen einen Beat immer? Ne, verschiedenes. Also ich gehe da eher so in die Richtung Techno-Dubstep, weil das unter Wasser halt so richtig dröhnt. Also es kann man jetzt ... Es klingt an Land jetzt wesentlich weniger cool, als wenn ihr alle bei mir in der Badewanne sässt, dann könnten wir das alles so ein bisschen besser.
Oh, wollen wir eine Live-Folge machen in einer grossen Badewanne?
Wie gross?
Gross genug für 600 Leute.
Ach so, okay, ja, das fände ich gut.
Schwimmbad, sagt man glaube ich dazu.
Ist eigentlich eine geile Idee.
Unter Wasser, mit Unterwasser-Mikros und wir haben so, und alle haben, also alle sind unter Wasser mit so Taucher-Equipment. Ja, Unterermikros ist, glaube ich, eh die Zukunft. Also nicht nur habe ich letztens ein Konzert gesehen unter Wasser, wo alle, also auf YouTube, wo alle ... Alles ist immer uncooler im Nachklapp. Wo tatsächlich, ich schaue ja oft so Weird Instruments und so. Ja, ich auch. Das ist ja so meine Art von Musik, so Leute, die sich irgendwie aus einem Besen und irgendwie so einem Biberfell dann irgendwie so ein neues Instrument kreieren und dann da draufhauen. Und dann so. Und du denkst dir, okay, ja, klar, du kannst dir auch ein bestehendes Instrument kaufen, aber jetzt halt das. Wo bleibt da der Spaß? Man muss keinen Biber töten.
Das stimmt. Du hast keinen guten Grund, einen Biber zu töten.
Da wird es eh mau an guten Gründen, einen Biber zu jagen.
Es wird auch immer Mauer.
Es wird immer Mauer. Im Laufe der Zeit wird es Mau, Mauer am Maus rüsten.
Und da gab es auch einen Auftritt von einer Band komplett unter Wasser.
Da standen auf der Bühne drei grosse Wassertanks in einem Schlagzeug, in einem Zaxophon. Da möchte ich eine Frage stellen. Wie formuliere ich Sie am besten diese Frage? Warum? Ja, an der Frage knabbern wir selber noch ein bisschen, gerade. Da können wir jetzt zum aktuellen Zustand noch nichts sagen. Wir melden uns noch mal bei Ihnen zurück. Also war erst die Idee, das Konzert unter Wasser zu spielen.
Das war die Ursprungsidee. Ja. Naja, das ist alles entstanden in der Jam-Session. Wir waren an einem See irgendwie in Schweden und haben da wirklich gejammt. Und es klang so toll und wir standen da so im Wasser, im Mondschein und es war alles so eine tolle Atmosphäre. Und wir versuchen seitdem verzweifelt, diese Atmosphäre von diesem einen Moment zu rekonstruieren. Und wir wissen nicht, woran es liegt. Liegt es am Wasser, liegt es an der schwedischen Nachtsonne, liegt es an der Fata Morgana, die uns da heimgesucht hat. Schweden, ja bekannt. Fata Morgana. Fata Morgana. Fata Morgana. Aber das klingt so nicht schwedisch. Daran müssen wir arbeiten. Schreiben wir uns auf, dass wir mit unserem Schwedisch arbeiten. Weil wir müssen nach, peu a peu müssen wir uns ein bisschen hinkriegen, dass wir besser... Schwedisch. To do. Vatma, vadinser? Vater Morgana. Ich gucke gerne norwegische Serien, habe ich für mich entdeckt. Ja, nenn mal drei. Scum. Ja, und die anderen. Aber das ist so, die machen gute Jugend-Coming-of-Age-Serien, machen die ganz fantastisch. Auch irgendwie, das ist ja ein sehr, sehr kleines Land vielleicht zu Deutschland, sehr viele gute junge SchauspielerInnen haben die da am Start und können alle, es finde ich fantastisch, gut geschrieben, sieht wahrscheinlich kein großes Budget, aber alles sieht auch gut aus, also muss man wirklich sagen, sind die uns voraus. Ich verstehe gar nichts, nee. Und dann wollte ich mehr davon, kennt man ja das Prinzip. Ui, nerviger, nerviger, räusperer. Man macht das ja eigentlich, um nicht zu stören. Also man macht das ja, um nicht husten zu müssen, um den Sprechpartner nicht zu stören. Man entscheidet sich für eine kleine Störung, um die grosse Störung zu vermeiden. Was du gemacht hast, das war unhilfreich jetzt, weil du hast eine sehr grosse Störer aus der kleinen Sache. Gut, dass du es angesprochen hast, ist natürlich für uns beide nochmal ein riesiger Windhose, die hier durchs Studio fegt und stört, nervt. Eine kalte Brise. Naja, ich wollte mehr von norwegischen coolen Serien, habe mir deswegen mein VPN auf Norwegisch gestellt, auch aus dem, der in Norwegien ist, und habe dann mehr geguckt. Und die gibt's aber alle nur auf Norwegisch. Aber immerhin mit norwegischen Untertiteln. Das heißt ... Du kannst genau nachlesen, was du nicht verstehst. Ah, das Wort kenne ich nicht. Genau, nebenbei habe ich mal Diepel offen. Also der ist ein ganz toller Übersetzer. Der ist übrigens die erste Firma aus Köln, die jetzt eine Milliardenbewertung hat an der Börse. Oder so. Vielen Dank Diepe, was ihr für den Standort Deutschland tut, ein kölsches Startup. Sehr schön, Kölle Startup. Aus der Podcast-Uvo-Initiative Köln Startup herausgegangen und erstaunlich viele Fehler wurden begangen, dass wir jetzt an diesen Milliarden nicht mitverdienen. Ja, das stimmt. Wir können leider nicht mehr das erste kölsche Milliardenprojekt werden, aber das erste Kölsche Billionenprojekt können wir noch werden. Also haltet euch ran. Wo stehen wir jetzt? Patreon.com slash das Podcast Ufo Ufo Wo stehen wir jetzt gerade? Also Ziel ist eine Billion, wir stehen jetzt gerade bei Tausi.
Ich glaube, wir sind jetzt bei Tausi. Tausi. Ich hau auch so viel Geld dumm raus einfach. Ich bin der dümmste Geldausgeber der Welt. Es ist so lächerlich. Du wirst zu mir. Du wirst zu mir. Also wirklich, es gibt ja immer wieder so Finanztage, wo man mal so ein bisschen seine Finanzen checkt und so, was ist los? Wie ich die mit so einer Kasse, wo man so einträgt und dann kommt hinten so dieser Block raus und du hast so einen Leihstift hinter dem Ohr. Und dann ziehst du raus und oh oh. Tatsächlich muss man sagen, wenn man so ein Tortendiagramm aufstellen würde, wofür gibst du dein Geld aus? Torten, Diagramme, dann wäre natürlich ein grosser, der größte Teil meines Budgets, Strafen, Strafzettel, Geschwindigkeitsüberschreitungen, Parkverbot, das sind alles vermeidbare... Dass du dich immer gegen deine einstweilige Verfügung hältst. Ja genau, Herr Will, das sind alles unnötige Ausgaben. Sie dürfen sich Timmy auf 60 Meter nicht nähern, was haben Sie daran nicht verstanden? Ich verstehe nicht, warum Sie andauern. Es geht sehr viel drauf in dem Monat. Ich bin so schlecht im Schätzen, sorry. Aber vergessen Sie ihn doch, vergessen Sie den kleinen Timmy doch, sondern gehen einfach woanders hin. Sie müssten nicht schätzen, wie weit das ist, wenn Sie einfach gar nicht mehr ihm hinterherlaufen würden. Ach, ich dachte, das wäre immer, man muss immer genau 60 Meter. Ich dachte, ach so. Ich dachte, das ist wie so eine Seile. In welchem Universum macht das Sinn? Was ist das für eine Strafe? Ich verstehe, das ist eine Strafe. Gut, dass wir uns jetzt mal ausgesprochen haben, dass wir uns jetzt geklärt haben. Ja, wir hatten es mit so einer It Follows-artigen Situation zu tun mit ihm. Gruselig, für alle Beteiligten. Für mich extrem anstrengend, für alle anderen sehr gruselig. Sehr gruselig, für alle Umständen sehr gruselig.
Ja, ich muss sagen, ist es wirklich erbärmlich, weil ich fahre ja oft Carsharing-Autos und wenn du da im Parkverbot stehst, dann ist es ja so, da kommt dann hier Ordnungsamt oder was und macht den Strafzettel und dann geht ein riesiger Domino-Day los von verschiedenen Behörden und Institutionen und dann muss das erstmalgt irgendwie, Schernau kriegt den Strafzettel, der muss dann rausfinden, wer hatte das Auto zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo wohnt der, wie heisst der, welche Ausnummer, welche Postleitzahl, wie viele Stellen hat die Postleitzahl, wo ist die Null, wo ist sie vorne, ist sie hinten, dann muss der Briefumschlag aufgemacht werden, dann muss das reingesteckt werden,
dann, ah, wo ist die Briefmarke,
alles automatisiert, wie viel
Porto hat das so und dann
wird es erst losgeschickt. Das heißt,
die Zeit zwischen Vergehen und Strafe
ist hoch, ist
gross, was natürlich den pädagogischen
Effekt mindert.
Weil du dich nicht mehr an dein Vergehen erinnern kannst. Ja, genau, und der bestrafende Effekt muss ja relativ so, oh, du nimmst einen Keks, zack, ich hau dir auf die Finger. Instant. Wie ein Hund. Weil wenn du einen Hund zu spät bestraft, weiss er nicht mal wofür. Richtig. Wenn du zwei Wochen wartest und ihm dann auf die Schnauze haust, dann kann der Hund nichts lernen. Nee, deswegen habe ich das Hundebeispiel genommen, weil da ist sogar, wenn du zwei Minuten zu spät das machst, weiss er schon nicht mehr, was gerade vorgefallen ist, wofür werde ich bestraft, fürs gute Benehmen, weil ich gerade, ich liege immer im Bett, warum werde ich angeschrien? Ja, und dann habe ich einen Strafzettel bekommen für irgendwie, sagen wir mal, Bogenbauergasse und dachte ich, ah, okay, scheiße, habe ich da irgendwo falsch geparkt. Auch ein guter Beruf übrigens. Genau, ah, scheiße, habe ich irgendwo falsch geparkt, naja, mal gucken, nächste Woche wieder ein Strafzettel, wieder Bogenbauergasse. Ich denke mir, hä? Mitten mal, okay, ja gut, da soll ich dann echt nicht mehr parken. Woche drauf, wieder Strafzettel, Bogenbauergasse. Die müssen jetzt gar nicht sein, schau auf Google Maps, was ist da genau? Und es ist da auf der anderen Seite des Edekas, wo ich manchmal auf dem Parkplatz parke. Genau. Da vorm Edeka. Da dachte ich, ach krass, okay, da darf man nicht parken. Okay, dann parke ich da nicht. Was wir seit 2012 wissen, aber nächste Woche wieder Strafzettel, Bogenbauergasse. Das kann ja jetzt nicht wahr sein, was ist denn da los? Und dann parke ich jetzt halt auf dem Parkplatz vom Edeka immer. Nächste Woche wieder Strafzettel, Bogenbauergasse. Und irgendwann stellt sich raus, dass der Parkplatz vom Edeka gemeint ist, obwohl die Adresse eigentlich die Straße vorm Edeka anzeigt, aber der Parkplatz vom Edeka hat eine automatische Kennzeichenerkennung und kontrolliert automatisch, wie lange Autos da stehen bleiben. Und wenn die länger als eine Stunde stehen, kriegst du automatischen Strafzettel.
Was ich nicht wusste, und ich habe da immer mein Auto abgestellt.
Und dann ist es eben manchmal nach einer Stunde war es schon weg und kam nicht rein.
Du wirst mit Fachbegriffen um dich, eine automatische Kennzeichenerkennung.
Haben wir es mit Kameras zu tun?
Kameras sind im Spiel.
Und du parkst vor der Kamera, winkst noch rein, gehst weg und wunderst dich, ob der vielen Strafzettel. Ich glaube,
da gibt es eine Kamera an der Einfahrt
zum Parkplatz oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Wie genial ist das denn? Das ist brillant.
Deswegen hat mich das auf dem kalten Fuß erwischt,
weil ich nicht damit gerechnet habe,
dass man mich so kriegt. Also ich bin ja
Outlaw, Renegade, ich bin es
eigentlich gewohnt, dem langen Hand,
dem langen Arm der Justiz
eigentlich zu entrinnen. Das ist eigentlich mein normales Leben. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, oh okay, ich hatte nie damit gerechnet, dass man auf dem Parkplatz nicht parken kann. Und jetzt war folgende Situation. Jetzt kam ja für den gesamten Delay jedes Mal noch jede Woche Strafzettel. Von welchen Delay reden wir eigentlich? Wir reden so von ... Zwei Wochen, drei Wochen? Zehn Wochen. Zehn Wochen! Das heißt, ich wusste, ich habe die letzten zehn Wochen alle immer noch mal diese Straftat begangen, falsch geparkt, und hatte jetzt vor mir diese Lawine, die jede Woche noch mal reintraut. Und wir reden über, also wie jede neue Stunde, die anbricht, wird noch mal ein Strafzettel ausgestellt? Nee, nur ab eine Stunde und dann ist die Straf begangen. Okay, ab eine Stunde und dann ist einmal die Strafe begangen und dann ist auch egal, wie lang es da steht, du kriegst dann nämlich 15 Euro Strafe. Genau, aber dadurch, dass diese Verzögerung so lang war, hatte ich jetzt noch plötzlich diesen riesigen Rattenschwanz, weil ich dachte, wenn ich jetzt aufhöre, dann hören in zehn Wochen die Strafzettel auf. Was 70 Strafzettel sind. Und ja, so habe ich, einfach weil ich richtig dumm bin und viel zu lange gebraucht habe, um zu checken, dass man nicht auf einem Parkplatz parken darf, habe ich diesen riesigen Kaskadeneffekt, der jetzt langsam noch auf mich reinprasselt. Und ich werde jetzt, das ist wie wenn du jetzt jede Woche erinnert wirst an irgendeinen Fehler, den du in der Schulzeit begangen hast und du so, ja, ich weiß und du machst das schon ewig nicht mehr, aber du kriegst trotzdem noch jede Woche den Strafzettel. Bei mir folgende Fragen. Du hast über 1000 Euro Strafzettel wahrscheinlich jetzt. Das weiß ich nicht, aber es ist erbärmlich. Das ist einfach unnötig. Und dann, meine Frage, weil ich glaube, man darf nicht unendlich viele, vor allem gerade in dieser kurzen Zeit akkumuliert, darf man ich, nicht wahnsinnig viele Parkvergehen haben. Ich glaube, irgendwann gilt das als vorsätzlich und wird mit Gefängnisstrafe für die durch die grossen angsterfüllten Augen, nein, aber sowas wie, dass du dann so eine, diese Nachuntersuchung machen musst, also nochmal einen Führerschein. Ach so, die GPU. MPU? MPU.
Wo steht das?
Mann, Pkw,
Union.
Mensch, Pkw,
Unit.
Können wir es konkreter fassen? Es ist noch sehr
vage. Naja, es ist eine ganz
eine grosse Bandbreite an
Vergehen, die hier wieder aufgenommen werden. Wir versuchen die Mensch-Maschine-Einheit. Mensch-Pkw- Union. Sie haben sich von ihrem Pkw entfernt. Ihr seid nicht mehr eins, ihr müsst jetzt wieder zurückgeführt werden. Das ist wie eine Paartherapie für Mensch und Maschine. Ja, und das ist richtig schlecht und du fühlst dich richtig, richtig dumm. Richtigm, weil du denkst dir, das ist so viel Geld, das hätte man für schöne Dinge benutzen können, aber jetzt kriegt es irgend so eine Halsabschneider-Kamera-Spionage-Firma, die überall einfach Kameras aufstellt und mich auflaufen lässt. Also ich glaube wirklich, dass du mit Punkten rechnen musst an irgendeinem Punkt. Wie? Ja, wer Strafzettel nur so sammelt, kann zu medizinisch-psychologischen Untersuchungen MPU vorgeladen werden. Woher weist denn Flensburg überhaupt von der ganzen Sache? Können wir das nicht unter uns klären? Flensburg hat seine Augen überall. Na, weiß ich nicht. Überall. Auch über die Grenzen Flensburgs hinaus. Also, auf sämtlichen Edeka-Parkplätzen haben die ihreiesen-Glubsch, das Auge Flensburgs wacht über ganz Deutschland. Ich dachte, es ist nur, wenn man in Flensburg was falsch macht, dann hat man Probleme. Das Auge Flensburg hat dich im Blick, mich im Blick. Es lauert, es sieht alles. Ja. Ja, nee, aber da möchte ich jetzt aber Berufung einlegen. Du hast ja ich Probleme, glaube ich. Ich werde vor Gericht diesen Clip abspielen. Mein Geständnis, ich bin geständig, heute. Ich möchte nicht, dass der Podcast-Ufos als Geständnis vor Gericht benutzt werden kann, weil dann habe ich ganz grosse Probleme. Ich will immer sagen, nee, es ist ein Witz, weil ein Witz, ein Comedy-Podcast. Ach so, wir können es ja auslegen, wie wir es wollen. Aber so haben wir noch die Geschworene als zusätzliche Hörer, ist doch gar nicht so schlecht. So, es gibt einen Falschparker, der innerhalb von nur zwei Jahren 83 Strafzettel gesammelt hat. Schlafzettel. Das ist ein ganz anderes Problem. Ja, ja, sorry, ich habe mich verraten, ich muss feier, verraten, hier, so, jetzt habe ich einen, der wurde innerhalb von zwei Jahren mit 83 Strafzetteln ausgestattet, weil er einer verordneten MPU nicht nachkam. Ah, okay, wurde ihm seine Fahrerlaubnis entzogen. Okay, das heißt, ich glaube, du wirst zur MPU vorgeladen, was mich persönlich als Co-Creator dieses Podcasts voll sehr freut, weil du dann irgendwann natürlich die MPU machen musst. Da musst du doch mal mit so 18-Jährigen in der Fahrschule sitzen. Das wäre natürlich meine Gelegenheit, meine Fahrschul-Revolution von innen heraus anzubringen. Dieses Wir fahren alle bei Grün an hat sich ja noch nicht durchgesetzt. Da gab es hier und da kritische Stimmen, aber auch Postimmen, die wir die letzte Woche gesammelt haben. Kannst du ja bei der Fahrschule Böttcher in der Grubenbauer Gasse. Ja, da fängt die Revolution an. Das ist meine Bastille. Und da fange ich dann an so, warum fahren wir eigentlich Herr Lehrer, eine Frage mal, warum fahren wir eigentlich an der Ampel nicht alle gleichzeitig an, hm? So, da bin ich nämlich undercover. Ich bin undercover und dann gar nicht so von innen her. Die Schirmmütze, die ich rausgehört habe, tief ins Gesicht gezogen. Und so können wir nämlich von innen heraus dieses System langsam zersetzen und verändern. Aber was ich lustig finde, es ist ja auch die medizinisch-psychologische Untersuchung. Und ich glaube, dass du komplett aus dem Verkehr gezogen wirst. Ja, aber wegen M oder wegen P? Ach so, wegen P, okay. Weil du zum ersten Mal zu einer P geladen wirst und dann werden die sagen, ja, wie verbringen sie ihre Tage so und dann wirst du sagen, also meistens beatbox ich unter Wasser und dann sagen die, okay. Nein, die sagen cool, yo. Nein, da geht ein roter Alarm an. Das Auge Flensburg schlägt Alarm und dann wirst du nach Mordor geschickt. Ja, kann sein. Ja, kann sein. Oh Gott, ich hoffe nicht. Naja gut, wir bleiben dran. Wir bleiben dran, aber es ist wirklich, ich bin gerade noch,
steckt in diese Lawine drin und kriegt ständig diese
dummen Strafzettel und es ist einfach wirklich wie so
ein Fehler, den man im Leben gemacht hat
und irgendwie ständig hinterher. Nee, du hast ihn 70 Mal gemacht,
aber ja, weil das steht ja auch
auf dem Parkplatz. Aber wenn du nicht weißt, dass es ein Fehler
ist, dann und es machst es, nein, du weißt
es nicht, dass man auf einem Parkplatz
nicht parken darf, ist für mich kein
Fehler. Carsharing-Autos und es ist ein Kundenparkplatz vom Edeka? I don't know. Ja, ich bin nicht so. Ich meine, du hoffst ja. Ich verstehe schon, bei Carsharing-Autos ist man ja einigermaßen schmerzfrei, weil man immer denkt, andere wollen das ja auch wahrscheinlich haben, gleich ist es eh weg. Ja, und es ist ein gewisser Zufallsfaktor. Ich komme meistens damit auch durch. Es ist ein gewisses Risiko, wenn du sagst, okay, du hast eine Stunde Zeit, wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jemand das mitnimmt, dann kannst du ja einfach gambeln und sagen, okay, wenn es nicht passiert, dann krieg ich einen Strafzettel. Ja, es ist ein negatives Gambeln, weil du kannst nie gewinnen. Genau, du kannst nur verlieren, ja, stimmt schon. Eigentlich ist es wie Gambeln. Ja. Gambeln. Es stimmt schon, aber du hast wenig Anreiz. Also so. Ja, Park, Free Parkplatz. Aber auf der anderen Seite hast du ja letzte Woche gesagt, wie wär's, wenn wir alle anfahren. Du hast die große Revolution ausgerufen. Genau. Kam da viel Zuspruch, kam was ein. Also, es gab intensive Diskussionen. Ich stecke oft im Verkehr fest in der Innenstadt und würde mir denken, warum sind alle Menschen eigentlich so dumm? Warum sind alle so dumm? Dieser Mensch, der neben mir im Auto steht, ist so dumm. Und vielleicht hat der einen Job, dass er irgendwie bei einer Krankenversicherung arbeitet und irgendwie irgendwann mal meinen Fall vor die Nase bekommt. Wie kann der dann so dumm sein? Wie kann diese Gesellschaft überhaupt funktionieren, wenn die alle so dumm sind? Das sind die Gedanken, die alle so blöde sind. Das sind die Gedanken, die ich mit dem Autofahren mache. In der Stimmung? Ja. Sehr distanzierte, ironische Stimmung. Es ist eine monotone, entkräftete Ermüde. Mich macht Wut eher müde. Du hast keine Kraft mehr. Ich habe keine Kraft mehr für Wut. Und deswegen war meine Idee, wir fahren alle bei Grün gleichzeitig an, gleichzeitig los, damit nicht immer erst Stück für Stück. Und es gibt tatsächlich ein Video, das mich bestärkt, das wurde auch in unserem Reddit gepostet, wo jemand gesagt hat, das ist tatsächlich ein Problem von so einem Städteplaner oder irgendein Journalist, der sich damit beschäftigt hat, dass das ein großes Problem ist und dass man so viele Probleme lösen könnte auf jeden Fall. Und deswegen versuche ich, diese Revolution durchzubringen. Gab viel Kritik, viel Feedback. Leider haben viele Menschen es falsch verstanden und dachten, man fährt einfach dumm stumpf los, wenn es grün ist.
Fährt man dann nicht auf? Gibt es da nicht Unfall? Ja, so ist es natürlich nicht gemeint, dass man einfach blind losfährt, sobald es grün ist, alle Autos. Sondern du bist bereit zu fahren. Du rechnest damit, dass es jetzt schon losgeht und bist bereit anzufahren. Und wenn sich alles in Bewegung setzt, bewält sich alles gleichzeitig in Bewegung. Nicht man fährt einfach los, egal ob der Vordermann fährt oder nicht. Was ich da überhaupt noch erklären muss. Seid ihr bescheuert? Dumm! Und deswegen schwierig, aber tatsächlich sehr, sehr still, sehr, sehr still geblieben, ist die Fraktion der Fahrlehrer. Da habe ich gar nichts bekommen. Ich glaube, die hören keine Podcasts. Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass Fahrlehrer, Fahrlehrerinnen keine Podcasts sind. Meinst du, aber haben nicht gerade die einen sehr hohen Bedarf an akustischer Untermalung? Nein, ich habe Fahrlehrer und Fahrlehrerinnen so kennengelernt, dass sie sehr, sehr, sehr so, eigentlich sind es so ein bisschen gescheiterte Stand-up-Comedians, die so bei sich immer, oder Rennfahrer. Bei uns war es dann immer so, man ist durch die Stadt gefahren, langsam so durch die Dreissiger-Zunge, und da waren so die Fahrschulen alle irgendwo verteilt über die Stadt. Und die hatten immer so bodentiefe Fenster, das waren alte Ladenlokale, da haben sie sich dann eingemietet, haben ihre Kurse gemacht. Und man sah dann immer in diesen Fenstern die kleinen Klassen und den Fahrlehrer, die Fahrlehrerin vorne. Und es wurde immer schallend gelacht. Da war ja vorne, es war auch noch so ein kleines Schuh-SM8, so ein kleines Mikrofon gefehlt, in das die so reinsprechen mit dem Kabel und dann wäre es einfach so ein Comedy-Seller gewesen. Alle, die haben sich immer so selbstverwirklich mit ihrem, weil die erzählen ja immer den gleichen Schmarrn. Und sobald du meinen Gag hast, hast du den für immer. Genau, richtig. Für immer, du kannst ihn jedes Jahr wieder neu machen. Und wenn er nicht mehr funktioniert bei den Leuten, dann schreichst du den raus, überlegst du den neuen. Und so haben sich aber Jahre halt super tight five. Tight five minutes. Die grossen fünf. Immer zusammengebastelt. Ey, das wäre aber auch ein geiles Setting für eine Serie, oder? Fahrschulen. Weiss ich nicht. Doch, glaube ich schon. Du hast da immer so diese jungen Leute, du hast so diesen Generationenkonflikt, dann hast du vielleicht so einen jungen Fahrlehrer, der irgendwie so ein bisschen immer mit den Schülern bonden will, aber die eigentlich auch keinen Bock auf den haben. Und dann hast du so Konkurrenz zu anderen Fahrschulen in der Stadt, könnte ich mir richtig gut vorstellen. So eine Ampel, ein Ampel-Duell. Ja, genau. Und eine Stunde und Viertelmeile. Aber die tatsächlich, und tatsächlich, ich kenne einen Fahrlehrer, der hat während der Fahrstunde immer eine CD gehabt, die man sich gemeinsam angehört hat, um die schmerzvollen Stunden ein wenig zu lindern, und zwar war das eine CD von Formel-1-Geräuschen. Also nicht Musik oder so, sondern einfach Nyao! Nyao! Eine CD. Das als CD.
Mit 18 Tracks zum Beispiel drauf.
Mit, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Tracks, aber wie viele Laps.
Einfach so wirklich 18 Laps und einfach nur diese Geräusche.
Und der fand das so cool.
So nervig.
Vor allem im Straßenverkehr.
Stell dir mal so einen Fahrschüler vor, der irgendwie verängstigt da im Lenkrad sitzt und der ganze Zeit denkt, wo kommen die so schnellen Autos her?
Was ich verstehen würde, wäre so Sirenen ab und zu.
Das ist ein Wettbewerb. so ein Fahrschüler vor, der irgendwie verängstigt da im Lenkrad sitzt und der ganze Zeit denkt wo kommen die in den Autos her? Was ich verstehen würde, wäre so Sirenen ab und zu. Also so Strassen, ablenkende Strassengeräusche. So eine Frau, die ruft du kannst nicht parken, du kannst nicht parken! Dann kommt so ein Typ, der irgendwie sagt grüner wird's nicht! So von hinten. Ja, um dich zu desensibilisieren, oder was? Ne, um quasi die Bedingungen schwieriger zu machen, als sie in Realität sind, damit du in schwierigen Bedingungen das lernst. Okay. Wie in einem Wellenbad Seepferlchen machen. Weiß ich nicht. Nur in der Schule gesprochen. Ist vielleicht nicht die beste Idee. Schwierig Schwimmlehrer, meldet euch. Gut, dann möchte ich ihn anstellen. Aber sowas, und dann so Sirene, ab und zu so eine Sirene, die haben so Dolby 5 zu 1 irgendwie so gepegelt, dass sie von hinten zu kommen scheint. Und ich will einfach nur massive Überstabationen. So dass, wenn dann tatsächlich eine Sirene kommt, der Faschel denkt, ah, das ist nur die CD. Das ist nur ein Dreckszirne. Und dann nicht aus dem Weg geht. Das ist doch gut. Dass er im echten Leben mit so 40 dann so hört die Sirene, macht dann so das Radio aus. Es gibt ja auch so Songs, wo eine Sirene drin ist oder so, was ja das dümmste, nervigste der Welt ist. Sind, glaube ich, verboten, im Radio zu spielen. Ja? Meine ich schon. Ach, das kann sein. Das machen manchmal Punk-KünstlerInnen, um das zu verhindern, dass der Song im kommerziellen Radio gespielt wird. Weiß ich nicht. Alles ausgedacht. Aber es macht Sinn, oder? Ergibt einigermaßen Sinn. Aber habe ich mir komplett ausgedacht. Aber vielleicht habe ich es immer gehört. Finde ich schön. Finde ich gut. Ja, also die sind auf jeden Fall sehr still geblieben, die Fahrlehrer. Nichts kam von denen.
Ich dachte mir, dass die sich jetzt irgendwie anfangen zu winden und naja, das können wir nicht machen, weil das ist gegen die Vorschrift oder irgendwie sowas. Oder dass die mir zumindest erklären, warum sie es nicht machen, warum das keine gute Idee ist. Aber anscheinend hören Fahrlehrer tatsächlich keinen Podcast. Deswegen, jetzt bitte von mir die Bitte, falls ihr gerade in der Fahrschule seid, dann fragt doch mal euren Fahrlehrer, eure Fahrlehrerin, wäre es okay, wenn wir während der Fahrstunde einen Podcast hören und dann spielt denen doch bitte die letzte Podcast-Folge vom Podcast-UFO vor, wo ich diese Idee pitche. Wir müssen dieses Wissen, müssen wir unter die Leute bringen, die was verändern können. Das kann sehr unangenehm werden, verstehe ich, aber wir müssen diesen Kampf alle gemeinsam kämpfen. Also, bitte, wow! So was, damit man die verwirrt. Finde ich sehr gut. Und also, versuch das mal so mit reinzubringen. Ich halte echt einen Schock, das ist alles antrainiert. Du hast einen kleinen Schock. Ich habe einen kleinen Schock bekommen. Versuch das mal bitte mit einzubringen und versucht so die Botschaft. Ich brauche Apostel. Letzten Endes brauche ich Apostel. Und man findet heutzutage einfach ... Kann ich ein Apostel sein? Naja, okay. Ich möchte nur einer von deinen ... Du bist der achte Apostel Nee, mach mal, achtzig, komm. Ich hab nur achtzig Apostel. Nee, ich mach achtzig. Jesus hatte zwölf. Nee, ich mach achtzig. Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Jünger und Apostel? Waren das denn zwölf Aposteln? Ich glaube schon, Apostel, da gehst du durch die Gegend und erzählst von der Heiligen Botschaft. Und Jünger ist halt, du bist halt jung. Oder halt eher so ein Angelegen. Junggeselle. Ich glaube, in dem Moment, in dem Jesus stirbt, werden die Jünger zu Aposteln. So, das ist jetzt mal eine steile These. Bros. Ja, erst sind es Kumpels Bros, aber wenn Jesus stirbt, dann sind es ja automatisch Apostel. Unabhängig davon, diese theologischen Diskussionen, du versuchst immer, lass uns, ich brauche Apostel, die meine Botschaft in die Welt bringen. Wir schaffen das, Leute. Wir haben es beim Ruheabteil nicht geschafft, also werden wir es jetzt schaffen. Okay, wir kriegen das hin. Mir ist etwas Schlimmes passiert, Flode. Ich möchte beichten. Ich möchte beichten.
Na gut.
Ich war in einem Zug in einem fremden Land und habe da mit meinem Kumpel geredet, laut gelacht.
Hahaha.
Spaß, Spaß, Spaß, Spaßeredet, laut gelacht.
Spaß, Spaß, Spaß, Spaß, fun, fun, fun, fun.
Ich möchte beichten, ich verstehe jetzt nicht, warum Sie jetzt diese ausrufen.
Ist das nicht so ein Safe Space?
Ach, vergib uns unsere Sünden.
Ich verstehe jetzt diese Haltung nicht.
Ich dachte, man kommt zum Sünden, um einigermaßen in so einem sicheren Raum zu sein. Angstfreier Raum, dachte ich, ist das hier. Das sind so diese judgy sounds von drüben. Machen Sie das mit Ihrer... Okay, also jedenfalls habe ich gesündigt. Ich war in einem Zugabteil, habe viel gelacht, viel Spaß gehabt. Und dann kam der fremdsprachige Schaffner vorbei und hat gesagt, hier ist Ruheabteil. Zu Recht. Und wir haben gesagt, ach shit, das wussten wir nicht, haben wir nicht gesehen. Kleine, mikroskopisch kleine Schilder am Rand sollten uns darauf hinweisen, dass das hier ein Ruheabteil ist, wussten wir nicht. Und danach haben wir die Klappe gehalten. Und es war ein Zug. Es war ein Zug und ich bin schuldig, ich habe mich schuldig gemacht. Und du hättest nicht, bevor du dich hingesetzt hast, mal gucken können, ist das ein Ruheabteil, ja oder nein? Ich verstehe es nicht, ich liege ja schon auf dem Boden. Warum du jetzt noch auf mich drauf sitzt? Du hattest irgendwie eine Sonnenbrille an und konntest dann nicht sehen genau oder hattest eine Mütze ins in die Augen gezogen? Hattest du den Hoodie ganz klein, das kleine Sichtfenster, Sonnenbrille auf, Maske noch auf, Augen. Okay. Und ich konnte auch nicht fühlen. Das heißt, du konntest auch deinen Kopf nicht so drehen, dass dein Blickfeld sich in die Richtung wendet, um nach Hinweisen auf ein Ruheabteil zu suchen. Das war dir nicht möglich. Du hattest irgendeine Halsverletzung oder sowas in der Richtung. Ja, nein, alles nicht. Ach, das ging. Ach so. Alles ging. Ach so, okay, das wäre also möglich gewesen. Das wäre alles möglich gewesen. Du hättest also, das darf ich nur kurz zusammenfassen, du hättest also vorausschauend danach suchen können, ob das ein Ruheabteil ist oder nicht, um dann dich adäquat auch den Fremden sitzen, um das fremden Landes als Gast in diesem Land, hättest du dann auch diese Gastfreundschaft erwidern können. Okay, alles klar, dann bin ich im Bilde. Die haben nur den Fehler gemacht. Es war innerhalb, das ist ja in Deutschland sogar, wo du quasi gerade deine Petition startest, ist ja am Rand steht er die ganze Zeit Ruhrabteil, Ruhrabteil, pss, pss, pss, pss, steht er am Rand. Da in diesem Waggon nicht. Da war draußen an der Tür, habe ich dann beim Rausgehen wieder gesehen, war ein Schild, hier ist Röhrabteil. Und dann bin ich da, aber weil man Gepäck hatte und so und da durchgegangen, habe ich nicht gesehen. Und innerhalb des Waggons hat einen niemand mehr erinnert, dass das hier das Röhrabteil ist. Es soll mich nicht von meiner Sünde befreien, das sollst du als mein Beispiel machen. Ich verachte dich trotzdem. Aber es kann auch passieren. Es kann Leuten passieren. Aber das Ding ist ja, ich höre ja dann aufzureden, wenn mir jemand sagt. Und was bei dem besser lief, jemand ging rum und hat höflich gesagt. Ja, das ist super, das ist gut. Ja. In der anderen Sprache. Aber ich habe verstanden, was du meinst. Die Geste ist sehr klar. Ja, die Geste ... Dir wurde ein Zeigefinger auf die Lippen gedrrückt und das stehst selbst du. Ja. Ja gut, hast du doch was gelernt. Ich habe was gelernt, sorry, Florentin. Comprendo. Si, comprendo. Aber auch da die Frage, kriegt man das nicht noch besser hin? Kriegt man nicht große Sticker an die Wände gemacht, dass man gezeigt bekommt, hier ist wirklich hohe Abteilung. Und nicht nur außen.
Ja, ich habe jetzt gesehen, so eine Art, ja, Bane.
Excuse me?
Der dritte, Dark Knight, Bane. Der hatte doch auch so eine Mundsch... Oh, Batman!
Wie du die einfach mal zweiter...
Oh, wen haben die denn hier?
2015, die du die einmal antrainiert hast und dann einfach jetzt Sail und noch Gelegenheit. Nicht besser geworden bist. Weißt du, du dachtest, ja, der Joker war so beliebt, jetzt trainiere ich mir endlich eine Bane-Imitation an. Dann war der Film nicht so beliebt, wie ich erhofft hatte. Und der hat ja auch so eine Box vorm Mund. Ja. Und die Idee soll jetzt auch umgesetzt werden, sodass du tatsächlich mit dieser Box vorm Mund telefonieren kannst. und niemand hört dich. Brillant. Niemand hört dich, nur dein Hörer ist in der Box, sodass es drin ist und niemand hört dich. Und das wäre für mich schon ein Riesenschritt, weil davon kaufe ich 200 Stück und verteile einfach diese Becher. Wie lustig, wenn das so accidentally auch genauso gefies aussieht wie bei Bane. Ja. Es gibt nur einen Hersteller, der das macht, es gibt nur einen, der das Monopol hat sich auch direkt paläutieren lassen. Der liebt Steampunk. Und er macht das einfach in so einem verzierten Fantasy-Org-Steampunk-Look. Und es sieht einfach, Totenköpfe zieren das alles und diese ganzen Businessleute mit so Anzügen und kaufen sich das dann, weil das der einzige Hersteller ist. Warum gibt es nicht ... Ah, du hast auch den Bone Reaver.
Ja, für geschäftliche ... Nee, das ist der Bonebreaker.
Der Stillmacher.
The Silencer.
Der Silencio.
Death zwei Silencer.
Ja, finde ich richtig gut.
Aber warum ist Monopol nie lustig?
Ja, gute Frage, man könnte wirklich viel daraus machen.
Wenn du eh schon Monopol hast, warum nicht dann auch mal draufhauen? Es ist nie lustig, es ist eher immer boring. Bahnen, es ist alles so langweilig. Aber dass sie mal, weil du könntest ja dann wirklich alles machen. Und Leute sind auf deine Produkte angewiesen. Und dann mal einfach mal all in gehen und so eine Steampunk-Ästhetik machen. Mit so Kupferzähnen, die so unten rauskommen. Es ist so ein weit aufgerissener, so Venom-artiger Riesenmund, so eine schwarze Maske und dann kommen so Goldzähne, sieht man dann so spitze, vampirartige Goldzähne kommen so raus. Aber es ist alles billiges Plastik, aber es riecht schämlich aus. Es riecht nach Karnevalmaske. Wir haben uns jetzt für ein zeitloses Design entschieden. Aber da drinnen ist diese geniale Technik, da drinnen ist dann die Technik, die Sinus-Cosinus-Kurve, keine Ahnung, gleicht das aus. Genau, kennst du das alles raus, du hörst nichts, es funktioniert perfekt. Und das wäre für mich wirklich ideal. Weil stell dir das vor, weil da kannst du dann auch, wenn du jemandem gegenüber sitzt, hast du diese Schale an und man telefoniert halt miteinander, obwohl man gegenüber sitzt, aber niemand um dich herum hört. Das ist fantastisch. Klar, Spione haben Riesenproblem,
Lippenleser sind raus!
Kinder
sehr viel Angst vor diesen Masken.
Kinder Todesangst
vor diesen furchtbaren
Ekelmasken. Ja, vor allem,
ich stell mir vor, die haben ja wahrscheinlich
auch so einen Knopf drauf, dass wenn du
kurz mit jemandem sprechen musst, dass
das Mikrofon nach außen geleitet wird. Das ist Stimmverzerrt. Das ist Stimmverzerrt. Hallo, hallo, ich hätte gerne einen Kaffee bitte. Ja, mit Milch oder mit Sahne? Gute Frage, Miss. Milch gern. Okay, die Milch. Milch gern. Milch gern.
Ich wache bis am.
Okay, ja, das sollte klappen, dann ist er gleich fertig.
Kriege ich meinen Anschluss noch?
Ja, na ja, also aktuell, wir haben ja zwölf Minuten Verspätung, aber wir versuchen es wirklich weniger zu werden zu lassen.
Versuchen Sie das besser.
Ja, okay, okay, alles klar, wir melden uns bei Ihnen. Danke. wirklich weniger zu werden zu lassen. Versuchen Sie das besser.
Okay, okay, alles klar, wir melden uns bei Ihnen.
Danke.
Ich liebe eine Stimme als Bain.
Alles, alles liebe ich an dieser Idee.
Ich möchte diese Masken herstellen.
Ich will, dass wir als Podcast-UFO GmbH, die es nicht gibt, aufkaufen,
die wir mal aufkaufen, eine Milliarde.
Ich meine, ich bin finanziell gerade leider ein bisschen eng da. Das ich Strafzettel. Aber das ist so scheiße, das ist immer deine Dreck Strafzettel. Immer einen grossen Strich durch unsere Zukunft machen. Ja, ich weiß, es tut mir leid, aber ich versuche besser. Aber das wäre auf jeden Fall ein Projekt, das finde ich sehr vielversprechend, dass du wirklich dadurch versuchst, die Welt leise zu machen, den Leuten diese Becher zu geben, die vielleicht sogar aushängen, so wie im Flugzeug, dass wenn ein gewisser Dezibelpegel überschritten ist Älteren die Maske auf, bevor Sie sich selbst die Maske aufsetzen.
Im Falle einer Störung durch Sie selbst werden Sie durch Schleudersitze aus dem Zug geworfen.
Dafür legen Sie bitte vorher die Warnweste an.
All das hätte vermieden können, wenn Sie einfach leise gewesen wären, wie es im Ruheabteil eigentlich üblich ist.
Ich glaube, Sie haben alle einen Schaden, dazu hätte es nie kommen dürfen. Vielen Dank, dass Sie mit der Deutschen Bahn fahren und bis bald. Es wäre ein Traum, es wäre ein Schritt in die nächste Richtung. Auch wenn man natürlich sagen könnte, okay, muss die Bahn jetzt wirklich darin investieren? Also vielleicht mache ich mich auch sehr unbeliebt. Das wäre mein Punkt. Wenn die Bahn jetzt ihr gesamtes Budget investiert in diese extrem teure, extrem moderne Noise-Canceling-Technologie und dann, wenn ihr trotzdem die Züge ausfallen, kaputt sind, die Reservierung nicht angezeigt wird. Ich stelle mir mal so vor, wie sie da, um das umzusetzen, mit diesen schallsicheren Kabinen, Schienen verkaufen müssen. Also Schienen, ich stelle mir vor, wie sie so Schienen zurückbauen, weil da seltene Metalle oder sowas oder seltene Erben werden verbraucht für diese Schienen und sie bauen die zurück.
Wir wissen nicht, was wir noch machen sollen und dann verkaufen sie Schienen.
Eine kurze Durchfahrer, wir kommen jetzt gleich in Hamm an.
Wie Sie vielleicht wissen, mussten leider die Gleise nach Wuppertal verkauft werden.
Bitte steigen Sie deswegen alle aus.
Wir haben Taxis vorgemietet, in die Sie alle einsteigen können, mit denen Sie nach Wuppertal fahren.
Dort können Sie dann Ihren Anschlusszug erreichen. Vielen Dank für die Deutsche Bahn und seien Sie leise. Und alle recken so die Fäuste in die Lüfte, aber man hört gar nichts. Alle so, es ist gut im Raum, aber man hört nichts. Alle schalten gleichzeitig die Stimmen an. Scheiss mal, scheiss mal!
Das finde ich auch passiert.
So, dann, die Stimmung ist gerade gut.
Das möchte ich gerne nutzen, um ja, die
die Überleitung jetzt hinzubekommen
zu einem Thema, was uns nicht gefällt.
Es ist mal wieder passiert,
ihr habt uns alle zahlreiche Mails geschrieben und zahlreiche Nachrichten, vielen Dank dafür, wir bitten das aber auch in Zukunft einfach zu unterlassen. Hier sind Stephans Dino-News! Ja, dieser Jingle wurde wie gesagt vorher aufgenommen, als es noch ein lustiges Thema war. Ja, der T-Rex hatte dicke Lippen. Über den Zähnen. Und sah nicht so furchterregend aus, wie wir das alle dachten. Haha, lustig, lustig. An dieser Stelle, ja, möchte ich mich von der modernen Wissenschaft komplett distanzieren? Ja, es kam eine neue Studie, eine neue Forschung raus, der T-Rex hatte Lippen und nach diesem Paper war es anscheinend auch ein gängiges Jagdverhalten, dass er seine Beute zu Tode geküsst hat und dann quasi auch nicht das Fleisch zerstückelt hat mit seinen Reiszählen, sondern es mehr aufgesaugt hat. Gelutscht, also es wurde nicht totgebissen, sondern er hat dann so einen Triceratops einfach langsam aufgelutscht. Ja, wie so ein Lutscher. Aber das war immerhin ein qualvoller Tod. Ja, absolut. Für die Gelutschten. Du wurdest erst totgeknutscht und dann langsam aufgeweicht und weggeschlebt. Wenn jetzt noch rauskommt, dass der T-Rex das gar nie wollte, sondern einfach nur Liebe verteilen wollte. Er konnte mich umarmen, weil er kein Schimmelärmchen hat. Stimmt. Ja, genau, er muss seine Liebe anders zeigen. Nein, er hatte wollustige, pralle Lippen. Ich zitiere kurz aus dem Spiegelartikel. Statt stets seine grossen, das ist wirklich auch jetzt schon wie den Zungenbrecher geschrieben, statt stets seine grossen, scharfen Zähne zu blätten, da wollte man jetzt schon mal die Leser abwenden. Ich habe das Gefühl, man will das nicht für lautlesende Podcaster. Das ist ein guter Copyright-Schutz,
dass man es nicht vorlesen kann,
wegen Zungenbrecher.
Statt stets seine grossen scharfen Zähne zu blecken,
soll der ikonische Tyrannosaurus Rex sie bei geschlossenen Mund verborgen haben.
Das berichten Forschende im Fachmagazin Science.
Wow, toller Name.
Ja, wow, aber auch vielen Dank.
Wie können wir ein wissenschaftliches Magazin nennen?
Science.
Knowledge.
Mega, wow, cool.
Wohl nicht creative.
Demnach waren die Zähne von T-Rex und anderen Theropoden, Dinosauriern von dünnen, schuppigen Lippen bedeckt.
Also Herpes oder was? Schuppige Lippen, was ist damit gemeint? Hatten die einen so grossen Labello, wenn im Sommer das ausgetrocknet?
Selbst bei einem weit geöffneten Maul seien nur die Spitzen zu sehen gewesen, berichten die Autoren.
Die Gesichter der Dinos glichen damit eher denen heutige Eidechsen oder Warane statt Krokodilen. Wer sich zuletzt Bilder von T-Rex und anderen Raubsauriern anschaute, sah riesige Dolchzähne, die aus den Kiefern herausragen. Man denke etwa an den angriffslustigen Tyrannosaurus in Jurassic Park. Einige Forschende dachten, die Zähne der Raubtiere seien einfach zu groß, um in ihren Mund zu passen, sagte Studienautor Thomas Cullen, Paläontologe an der Auburn University in Alabama. Doch als Wissenschaftlerin und Wissenschaftler die Schädel von Dinosauriern und lebenden Reptilien verglichen, mussten sie die Annahme überdenken. Einige grosse Warane haben im Vergleich zu ihrer Schädelgröße größere Zähne als ein T-Rex, diese aber passen unter eine Reihe schuppiger Lippen, sagte Cullen. Das sei auch bei der ausschließlich auf den nördlichen Inseln verbreiteten Brückenechse Tuatara, so die aus der Dienzeit bis heute überlebt hat. Oder sind die nicht davor auf die Idee gekommen, die mal mit Eidechsen zu vergleichen? Jetzt kommt da jemand auf die Idee, oder was? In der Vogelrichtung hat man sich irgendwie verrannt. Wirklich komplett verrannt. So, und jetzt, ja, vielen Dank für eure zahlreichen schadenfrohen Nachrichten. Ich war gestern in der Jurassic World Exhibition, der Jurassic World Experience in Köln. Da hat im Odysseum, das ist eigentlich so ein Kindermuseum, wo ab und zu so interaktive Ausstellungen sind, ist jetzt die Jurassic World Exhibition. Das ist irgendwie so eine große Produktion, die rumtourt. Hat das was mit der Jurassic World Film Franchise zu tun? Ja, leider ja. Ich als großer Jurassic Park Fan des allerersten Teils finde ich nach wie vor einer der besten Filme aller Zeiten, habe mich da sehr darauf gefreut, bin hingegangen, eine Freundin hatte Karten gewonnen, wir sind da hin und ich gewinne andauernd um Ecken Karten, ich liebe alles daran. Und dann waren wir da und es war eigentlich einigermaßen ganz cool gemacht, also man ist da rein, wurde direkt von so Leuten, also es waren alles, wo waren Schauspieler, die halt so Ranger-Outfits anhatten, so, so Park Ranger Outfits, und dann ist man mit so der Musik von John Williams und leider auch Michael Giacchino, der tolle Musik macht, aber ich mag halt sehr, sehr gerne den John Williams Original Squad, natürlich wissen wir alle, Dinosaurier, Dinosaurier, pass auf, dass sie uns beißen. Und dann sind wir da rein. Oder jetzt in Todlutschen.
Und das war eigentlich ganz schön gemacht.
Es wurde halt ein Urwald nachgebaut,
mit viel Animatronik und so wurden coole Dinos.
Und wo ist das? In so einer grossen Halle?
Ja, so ein Riesenmuseum.
Und da haben die das umgebaut zu einem grossen Dino-Erlebnis.
Einen Jurassic Park.
Ja, aber gab's Dinos oder nur ... Doch, eine Menge Dinos gab's, die sind da rumgelaufen. Eigentlich haben sich alle sehr viel Mühe gegeben. So, jetzt war es nur so, dass man, während man durch den Jurassic World lief, die ganze Zeit dachte, klar, im Film wird das ja gebrochen. Alles kriegt am Ende, kriegt man den Anschein, ah, Zoos, vielleicht nicht so geil. Dinosaurier in die Jetztzeit zurückzuholen, vielleicht nicht so toll. Wäre man aber durch diesen ausgedachten Park läuft, kriegt man das Erleben ja nicht. Da funktioniert ja alles. Das macht die Botschaft von Jurassic Park wieder kaputt. Es weicht die komplett auf.
Ja, ich verstehe. Das heißt, da laufen dann vor allem
kleine Kinder rum, die sich freuen
und dass da
diese Velociraptoren,
die sehr schrecklichen neuen Filmen,
das war alles sehr scheiße, auch weil die ganzen,
es basiert auch nur auf den neuen Filmen, die alle ganz, ganz schlecht sind,
aber dann waren die in so
Gittern festgemacht und
wollten sich so bewegen, ein bisschen wie wenn Pferde irgendwie wahrscheinlich.
Und es sind so animatronische Roboter. Richtig, genau. Alles ganz toll gemacht, war auch sehr immersive, so die ganze Erfahrung, aber hat halt an dieser Grundaussage, Kernaussage gekrankt ein bisschen, weil alles sehr gut funktioniert am Anfang. Und dann war es halt sehr lustig, weil da waren halt dann Schauspieler, die halt dann diese Ranger gespielt haben.
Und ich dachte, dass ich das jetzt aufweiche ein bisschen. Ich weiß nicht, und dann dachte ich so, cool, man kann mit denen doch so hier umimproven. Und als jemand, der den ersten Teil sehr gut kennt, und dann war da halt dann, habe ich wiedererkannt, so ein Labor aufgebaut. und dann konnte mit so Handschuhen in einen, so ein Glas, so eine Glaskuppel reingreifen und da war Dino-Code drin. Und dann habe ich mich an die Laura Dern-Szene aus dem ersten Teil erinnert, wo sie sagt, diese Pflanzen, die sollte es hier gar nicht geben. Sie stellen die hier hin, weil sie gut aussehen, aber sie sind giftig für die Dinosaurier. So, dann dachte ich mir, kann ich das jetzt mit diesem Ranger besprechen? Sein Job ist nur den Kindern zu sagen, weiß ich nicht, ob sie mal so den kleinen Baby-Tyrannosaurus streicheln wollen, was dann so ein Puppentier auf dem Arm seiner Kollegin war oder sowas. Und dann habe ich das laut gesagt und es kam keine Reaktion von ihm. Und es war nicht so lustig. Und ich dachte, weil er hat, die haben halt, und dann waren halt auch die, diese Velociraptoren waren in ihren Käfigen eingesperrt und es fehlte eine. Und dann hat mein Kumpel auch gefragt, wo ist denn Blue? Wo stand oben drüber, standen die Namen. Und er war ein erwachsener Mann. Und sie hat gesagt, ja, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Das heißt, alle Fragen, die vom Publikum kommen, waren gedacht und direkt gespiegelt als, ah, okay, von Kinder stellen jetzt diese Fragen. Und geprobt an Kindern, ja. Geprobt an Kindern, richtig. Und ich glaube, das Skript war sehr tight, sehr eng. Und es war nicht so viel Platz für so Improv-Bits. Das heißt, ich bin die ganze Zeit, ja, gegen diese Schauspieler. Ja, und wo ist Blue? So, Blue war dann nebenan, dann haben sie einen Schauspieler, ohne Scheiß engagiert, der ein bisschen aussieht wie Chris Pratt. Und der hat dann so eine Fütterungsshow gemacht mit Blue, wie man es im Zoo kennt. Tier wird rausgeholt, er hat Futter dabei gehabt, hat ein paar Tricks mit ihr aufgeführt und dann ist Blue wieder gegangen. Dann geht man weiter und dann plötzlich bei der letzten Station kippt es ein bisschen, weil dann wurde der T-Rex vorgestellt und dann haben zwei Schauspieler standen an diesem Zaun und wollten den T-Rex erklären. In dem Moment geht ein Alarm an, das ganze Licht geht aus, und der Stromzaun geht aus, wie im Film. Und dann spielen die beiden, spielen während der T-Rex kommt und den Zaun abtastet und guckt, ob er uns alle fressen kann, Kinder haben Pafanik, die mit uns in diesem Raum waren, müssten die beiden Schauspieler Todesangst spielen. Ja. Das sind nicht wahrscheinlich die erfahrensten Schauspieler, die beiden. Und es war unglaublich hart, das zu schauen, weil die mussten einfach fünf Minuten lang mussten sie Todesangst spielen, indem sie 20 cm von unseren Gesichten entfernt standen. Wie undankbar ist das denn so als erster Schauspieler-Gig in so einer interaktiven Ausstellung? Vor allem Todesangst, aber normalerweise würde man in Todesangst ja fliehen. Aber das konnten die ja nicht. Das heißt, sie mussten zwar die Emotionen spielen, aber nicht das, was daraus folgt, konsequent dann auch machen. Und ich glaube, es war noch schlimmer, weil es waren ja auch Kinder da. Du musst Todesangst spielen, aber du darfst nicht Todesangst spielen. Weil Kinder dabei sind. Das ist für Sechsjährige, die dann da den Jurassic World angucken. Das heißt, du musst Todesangst spielen, darfst aber nicht fliehen, darfst aber auch nicht so hart Todesangst spielen, dass Kinder Panik bekommen. Dafür sollte es auch mal einen Preis, einen Schauspielpreis geben. Einen Oscar wirklich. Also nicht nur für diese Meryl Streep ist irgendwie in einem perfekten Skript, in einem perfekt ausgeleuchteten Set, mit einem perfekten Regisseur und gewinnt den Oscar, sondern die, die es wirklich hart haben, diese wirklich ... diese Extremschauspieler, die wirklich unter solch widrigen Bedingungen einfach durchpowern, die sollten auch einen Preis kriegen. Und dann war die ganze Zeit ... Und dann ging der Zaun wieder an, der T-Rex zog sich zurück und dann ging die Tür auf zum nächsten Raum und der eine Schauspieler sagte zu mir, ja sorry, sorry, dass es jetzt irgendwie so schief ging hier. Ich wusste aber nicht, weil ich war die ganze Zeit im Modus, ich will euch was geben, ich möchte mit euch spielen, ich möchte es auch für die Kinder immersiv machen und ich möchte einer von euch sein. Ja, du bist in der sein. Aber ich wusste nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll,
weil ich habe gedacht, ich spiele jetzt so einen deutschen Touristen,
der im Jurassic World ist
und der läuft natürlich kopfschüttelnd dann raus.
Wenn der zu mir sagt, ja sorry,
das hätte nicht passieren dürfen, es tut mir sehr leid,
dann habe ich gesagt, ich bin kopfgeschüttelt und mir rausgegangen
und dann war man im Giftjob
und dann war man plötzlich
in den Shop.
Aber ich fand das so, alles daran,
alle Schauschläfte hatten mir so, so
doll leid, aber
Vielen Dank. Ah nein! Und dann war man plötzlich ... ja, in den Shop. Aber ich fand das so ... alles daran, die Schauspieler, alle Schauspieler hatten mir so, so doll leid. Aber ich möchte, dass ihr alle, wenn ihr die Chance habt und das Geld überhaupt und da irgendwie Bock drauf habt, das ist keine coole Ausstellung, aber ihr könnt da hingehen. Allein wegen der Schauspieler und Schauspielerinnen. Aber ich find's richtig cool, dass du dich so als Teil des Ensembles verstehst. Und auch so nach der Show gehst du dann zu den rauchenden Schauspielern und meinst so, pfff, geile Show heute, oder? Also der zweite Akt, das war richtig tight. Aber ey, Uwe, du musst Todesang spielen, das hat das erst dann schon gesagt. Ja, ja, ich weiß. Du musst da Todesang spielen. Scheiß auf die Kinder im Raum, scheiß auf die Kinder. Ja, pack um dich, reiss ihnen Feuerlöscher runter, ja, das muss mehr kommen. Wirf ein Kind ins Maul des T-Rexes.
Ja, Opfer das Kind, da muss mehr kommen.
Also die Schoweffekte und so war alles ziemlich cool, die Dinos sahen wirklich sehr echt aus, alles war richtig cool gemacht.
Leider halt basiert es auf dem komplett falschen Film, nur Nonsens.
Dann war die Kernbotschaft bis auf das letzte, wo es dann wirklich ein bisschen nach hinten losgeht, eigentlich eher, Arzos sind ziemlich cool, Dinos festzuhalten und in der Gefangenschaft aufwachsen zu lassen.
Ist das eine Art, die wir uns alle stellen. Hatten die Lippen? Nein. Nein, euer Ehren. Wie undankbar ist das eigentlich, wenn während so einer Ausstellung so ein Artikel veröffentlicht wird und alle denken so, okay, fuck, wir brauchen Tape, wir brauchen, hol mir einen Fahrradschlauch, wir brauchen 200 Fahrradschläuche. Hier sind die Lippenstifte, die Sie bestellt hatten. Okay, grösser, die müssen grösser sein, die sind viel zu klein. Ich habe 50 besorgt. Okay, na gut, dann mach dich an der Arbeit. Los, Tamara, schnell, die Schläuche! Dann muss alles noch mal umgebaut werden. Aber würdest du denn sagen, dass diese Dinos in dieser Ausstellung eher dem wissenschaftlichen Stand getreu war oder eher der Märchenfantasie? Jurassic World. Das waren einfach die Jurassic World Dinos. Die waren auch teilweise blau und so. Auch weirde Entscheidungen, bei diesen neuen Fil Film, die einfach so Farbe zu machen und so auch.
Vor allem, man guckt das ja, weil man Dinos mag. Du, Stefan, es würde mich nicht wundern,
wenn in zwei Wochen Artikel rauskommt, T-Rex war blau.
T-Rex hatte blau. Okay, also du musst
in diesem Klima auch mit einer
gewissen Offenheit
diese Sachen gestalten, weil du weißt nicht, was
noch kommt. Du sagst einfach, gib dem gelbe
Streifen, weil wir wissen nicht, in zwei Wochen
ist es vielleicht so. Rally, so Rally-Streifen. T-Rex hatte R Rally-Streifen. Gib dem so tribal, gib dem so gelbe tribal Muster. At this point nehme ich gerne an, gegenüber grossen Knutschielippen nehme ich das gerne an. Es war unglaublich lustig, alles daran war so lustig. Jetzt wäre ich gern Schauspieler in sowas. Ja, total. Also ich glaube, das ist so der klassische Musical-Darsteller, wo man dann irgendwie mit hundert anderen Leuten auf die Schule geht und man weiß genau, einer geht ans Wiener Musical-Theater und 99 sind Ranger in Jurassic World. The Exhibition. Ist ein harter Job, ist ein harter Job. Aber mir gingen auch irgendwann die Zitate aus, weshalb ich dann mich vor jede Pflanze gekniet habe und gesagt habe, sie stellen die hier hin, weil sie gut aussehen. Dabei sind sie giftig. Naja, aber es war zwar cool, es war nicht schlecht, aber ich glaube, es hat irgendwie 27 Euro gekostet oder sowas. Ich finde gut, dass deine Dino-Liebe noch ungebrochen ist und dass du dich von der Wissenschaft nicht entmutigen lässt und dass du weiterhin dieses Fantasiebild auch aufrechterhältst und wieder gegen kämpfen, weil genau so muss es sein und ich finde, das ist genau richtig, wie du das machst, Stefan. Ich finde das genau richtig, ich finde das richtig gut. Ja, ich finde es auch gut. Also ich, wie gesagt, es ist so eine Fifty-fifty-ja-nein-Empfehlung. Okay. Entscheidet selbst, ob ihr dahin gehen wollt, aber wenn,, dann möchte ich, dass ihr mit den Schauspielern improvisiert und guckt, was da passiert. Aber sagt davor, klärt das auf, seid nicht wütend auf die Schauspieler oder sowas und denkt dann, die würden das verstehen, oder wie du genervt, wo die wahrscheinlich einfach dachten, okay, du bist wirklich genervt, weil du bist ein fantastischer Schauspieler und kannst das gut darstellen. Acting, acting, the art of acting.
Ja, aber gut, die Biologie hat man wieder zugeschlagen.
Und es ist einfach ...
Ja, ich meine, ich glaube, die Biologie rächt sich jetzt dafür,
dass bisher der Karrierehöhepunkt eines Biologen war,
ein Funfact, auf einer Party zu sein.
So, das war der Höhepunkt der Biologiewissenschaft, war auf einer Party, hey, wusstest du, dass Lemuren bis zu 20 Partner haben können? Weißt du was, Joe, halt deine Fresse. Halt deine Fresse, alles, was aus seinem Biologenmund kommt, ist alles langweilig, langweilig. Wir haben zwölf Jahre lang geforscht und hundert Lemuren. Alles klar. Weißt du, nimm jetzt hier, Pina Colada, bitteschön. So, jetzt Exodene. So, dann gehst du auf die Tanzfläche, tanzt du Pokerface und dann sehe ich dich nie wiedersehen. Ich kann ja diesen Ballstanz von Lemuren machen, weil wir haben nämlich... Raus, raus. Und das ist die Rache. Und jetzt fangen sie an, die Welt zu sabotieren. Und jetzt sagen sie so, was ist euch wichtig? Und jetzt machen wir euch die Dinos kaputt. Löwen übrigens, wollt ihr ein paar Fakten über Löwen? Wir alle sehen Löwen. Eure starken, mächtigen Löwen. Ja, wir wissen, wie sie aussehen. Die sind so klein wie ein Dackel. Wir sehen Löwen. Die sind so klein wie ein Dackel, die werden künstlich größer gemacht. Löwen sind klein wie ein Dackel, Adler können maximalig Meter weit fliegen. Okay, Adler können maximal
zwanzig Meter weit fliegen, dann müssen sie flattern
wie so ein Hühnchen und Schlangen
sind nicht giftig. Es gibt
keine giftigen Schlangen. Was kommt denn da raus?
Haben wir uns alle ausgedacht. Speiche,
die Saban. Da kommt Zuckerwasser raus.
Wir machen, also
wirklich, wir zerstören jetzt
alle, alles, was Leute cool finden.
Fledermäuse beissen dich nicht. Nein, sie küssen dich.
Es sind kleine Küsse, so küssen sie sich auch.
Klein bisschen Liebe schenken.
Ja.
Leg dich nie mit dem Biologen an.
Der kann wirklich alles zerstören, was du liebst. Alles.
Der macht dich kaputt auf eine ganz andere Art.
Ich meine, die Physiker haben uns Pluto genommen. Jetzt ist wieder Frieden mit den Physikern. Wir wollen nicht Venus auch noch verlieren. Aber die Biologen, die sind gerade auf dem Vormarsch. Das wird hart. Ja, da müssen wir aufpassen. Und wir merken ja jetzt, dass sie schon am Zuschlagen dran sind. Vielen Dank. Das war die Pressekonferenz des Verteidigungsministeriums. Der Diener. Der Verteidigungsminister Stefan. Ja, wir haben gemerkt, dass sie jetzt am Zuschlagen sind. Dass wir dran sind. Das gilt meiner Meinung nach ab jetzt. Was gab es vor Dinos eigentlich? Also gab es da noch coolere Dinos? Quallen. Quallen, viele Quallen. Okay. Viele lustige. Die auch ausgestorben sind, aber für die sich nicht mehr. Nee, die gibt es teilweise noch. Dafür, dass es Alligatoren übrigens auch damals schon gab, finden wir die einigermaßen ... Also wir geben denen nicht genug Credit dafür, dass sie schon damals ... Die haben die Dinos überlebt, die sind krasser als die Dinos. Immer noch, die sind krasser da, die sehen auch extrem cool aus, objektiv betrachtet. Wie haben die den Meteoriten überlebt? Was ist deren Geheimnis? Was können Krokodile, was Dinos nicht können? Die haben ein Geheimnis, die tragen ein Geheimnis mit sich rum. Haben die sich irgendwie so einen geheimen Atombunker gebaut oder unter Watte so Baumwollbäumen versteckt oder was? Dann ist Rüstungen gestrickt. Irgendwas willst du nicht? Ich will es gar nicht wissen. Doch, ich will es wissen. Ich will es nicht wissen. Das ist eine uncoole Kackerklärung wahrscheinlich. Oder gibt es die jetzt wieder? Aber das ist eine gute Frage. Gibt es die jetzt wieder? Ist das so ein Retro-Krokodil oder was? Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Oder hat sich die Natur entschlossen, die waren richtig cool, das war das Coolste, die machen wir jetzt nochmal. Ja, vor allem, also kann es ja nicht auch so sein, dass die Evolution schon so ein paar Benchmarks hat. Also wenn, jetzt sagen wir mal, irgendwas stirbt aus, dann sagt die Natur, ja gut, dann nimm den, also angenommen mit Alligatorensterben aus, dann sagen sie, na gut, dann nimm den Pfau und entwickle den mal so in Richtung Alligator, dass dann am Ende der Pfau wieder genauso wie der Alligator von früher ist, wenn die aussterben, dass sie dann so sagen, okay, da haben wir keinen mehr, ja, müssen wir halt gucken, so halt so Ersatz, Ersattiere, die dann in die Richtung, weil der Alligator hatte ja einen Platz im Ökosystem, der ist ja dann frei. Wenn ein Tier ausstirbt, ist ja Platz frei. Und dann kann ein anderes Tier in diese Lücke hinein evolutionieren und sieht am Ende vielleicht wieder genauso aus wie das Tier, was es ersetzt hat. Vielleicht passt es am Ende wieder, dass da dann mehr Artenvielfalt möglich ist. Deswegen mache ich mir auch gar keine Sorgen, dass so viele Tiere aktuell aussterben, weil ich mir denke, so wie ich mir das gerade gedanklich zurechtgelegt habe, so macht das überhaupt keinen Unterschied. Deswegen ist der Klimawandel gar kein Problem. Genau. Und die steigende Ungleichheit... Du musst nur dir kurz ein paar fadenscheinige Argumente überlegen, warum es gar nicht so schlimm ist. Und dann ist alles in Ordnung. Perfekt. Und deswegen wählt Florentins Verkehrspartei mit längeren Grünphasen, da haben wir alle was davon. Ja, mehr Grün, weniger Rot. Das ist auch nicht politisch gemeint. Gelb kann genauso viel bleiben, wie wir es bislang haben. Ich will die aktuelle Regierung mit genauso viel Gelb, weniger Rot und mehr Grün. Das ist jetzt ungünstig, dass die Ampel, also, ja, also, wir machen die Hubpartei, wir machen einfach die Hubpartei. Hub, Hub, Hub, Hub, aber es gibt keine Farben mehr, ne? Wie? Es gibt keine Farben mehr für die Politik. Ach so, meinst du das? Doch, doch, doch, gibt es noch ein paar Farben. Orange ist jetzt wieder frei geworden. Piraten ist orange. Du hast ja gewisserweise recht mit deinem, Plätze werden bakant, weil die Piratenpartei hat ja orange gehabt. Ja, aber das ist für immer orange. Ich finde es nicht mehr richtig. Aber sowas wie Silber oder so wäre auch cool, oder? Ja, so Gold, Platin, meinst du nicht so Silber? Platin ist wie Silber. Naja. Also wie willst du es darstellen? Wie will Jörn Schönborg? Na, ich will, dass in der Tagesschau, wenn dann so die Balken kommen, dass ein Balken so glänzt, so schimmert, weil das ist ja Silber. Das ist ja nicht grau, sondern Silber. Mit viel zu viel Mühe, so gleich glitzert. Das ist so wie Chrom, so wirklich so blitzend blank poliert und so, weil das muss ja schon dargestellt werden. Ich glaube, psychologisch auch wahnsinnig clever, weil man will ja, dass dieser Balten grösser ist. Ja, genau. Man will ja mehr von diesem schönen Glitzereffekt haben. Auf jeden Fall, das sieht wertig aus. Und transparent finde ich auch schön. Oh, die Glaspartei. Man sieht da durch. Das finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Transparente Partei. So Milchglas. Das weiss ich noch, wie es damals bei Windows Vista zum ersten Mal transparente Elemente gab. Wow. Wie zum Beispiel unten, ja, Windows Vista hast du dann unten auf das Windows-Zeichen gedrückt, und dann kam ja dieses Pop-up-Menü, und dann hast du so deinen Hintergrund noch durchgesehen. Da dachte ich mir, das ist der Future. Es geht nicht besser, Windows Vista ist State of the Art. Das ist die Zukunft, das werde ich den Rest meines Lebens benutzen. Windows Vista werde ich den Rest meines Lebens benutzen, und ich bin stolz darauf. Krass. Ja, vielen Dank für die vielen Artikel. Hört jetzt auf, uns das zu schicken, einfach, weil wir genug bekommen haben. Generell bei Dino News. Ja, aber ich glaube, da ist eine gewisse Gehässigkeit drin, weil die Leute wissen, dass wir Dinos lieben und die hauen drauf. Und naja, es ist auch viel Anteilnahme und man versucht, sich gegenseitig zu trösten. Ich glaube, die Dinos kommen irgendwann zurück. Wir müssen jetzt, glaube ich, noch irgendwie
ja, der Pferdeschwanz, irgendwie die
blauen Punkte und alles müssen wir
jetzt noch durch, aber ich glaube, sie kommen
irgendwann zurück und zur Not schlagen
wir zurück. Dann nehmen wir den Biologen
das, was sie am liebsten mögen.
Mikroskope.
Irgendwie sowas.
Ihre gemeine Mikroskope.
Die nur Unheil angerichtet haben
in den letzten Jahren. Sie haben nichts erreicht.
So oder so wird es weitergehen,
denn wir haben uns entschlossen, nächste Woche
noch eine Folge zu machen. Und bis dahin,
habt eine schöne Woche. Haut rein.
Kommt gut durch die Woche. Macht's gut. Wir heben. It's a worst bird production.